hello there from a secret snowman
building skill to a memorial for a
Fallen Hero here are 40 Secrets Easter
eggs and amazing details in Hogwarts
Legacy every game needs a Dark Souls
Easter egg it's a simple concept a sword
in a bonfire you've seen it 50 times
before well Hogwarts has got one too at
this location just look at this little
dude with his mighty sword feel free to
light that bonfire he doesn't mind in
fact this entire area seems to be a from
software homage with a gravesite like
those seen in Dark Souls and headstones
set in the wall like stepping stones
just like Eldon ring amazing back to the
little dude on the sword I'm told this
is based on a mandrake and this toy
version pops up everywhere in game doing
completely random things like this in
the opening Mission you can find one
chilling on a cliff Edge eating popcorn
with a niffler friend those Bros can be
also found on the hilltop near Hogwarts
having a tea party no less and a brew is
there for you if you want one too I'm
sure these guys appear elsewhere in the
game if you find them please let me know
many players have located what will be
Hagrid's of bold near the grounds of the
school just like in the movies yet here
is a very sad Easter egg and gravestone
sits in honor of Robbie Coltrane the
actor who played Hagrid I'll not be here
sadly but
don't you think on it for one minute but
Haggard will Robbie passed away in 2022
damn that was sad that was really sad
one of the treasure map missions has us
play a very specific tune on these bells
once complete it quickly becomes
apparent it's hedwig's theme
[Music]
Harry Potter's legendary music by John
Williams is playable in game in one of
the puzzle doors scattered around
Hogwarts it's possible to find a
painting of Medusa the legendary
Snakehead woman who could turn anyone
she looked at into stone the thing is by
looking at the painting we'll return to
Stone which is probably what happened to
everything else in this room everything
is solid Stone oh and I didn't notice
this until I started editing but look at
the painting again and the dude in the
picture he changes from a normal human
being to a man of stone human Stone man
magic an amazing detail you may have
totally missed can be found during
winter the snowmen are alive and watch
you from a distance and if you cast a
basic spell on them they'll retaliate
with a snowball things get even more
insane if you melt them using one of
your fire abilities don't worry a colder
spell can reform them again
it's like being in Frozen
[Music]
Hogwarts Legacy is set 100 years or so
before the books which lets future
stories be referenced in game for
example in the library it's possible to
locate this book secrets of the darkest
Arts
I'm impressed it turns out this is one
of the most important plot points in the
movies and in the game it's just a
throwaway line as you're breaking the
rules going on your own adventure in the
Slytherin bathroom it's possible to find
the place that will uncover the Chamber
of Secrets look closely the etching on
the tap in-game and the accompanying
text tells us nobody has any idea what
this could mean that revelation will
take a few more generations to be
uncovered another reference can be found
in the girls lose in one of the Stalls
is a cauldron and someone is brewing
Polyjuice just like Hermione does 100
years later
I wouldn't drink that an early quest
that can be picked up at the three
broomsticks is all about following
butterflies you want me to follow the
butterflies I yes not scary at all right
well this is actually thanks to Ron and
a quote from the movies follow the
spiders why spiders why couldn't we
follow the butterflies random thought
did you know there's a trophy or
achievement in game for flipping over a
cow 10 times legit flippendo is
underrated have you ever tried walking
around Hogwarts in your pjs it turns out
the devs expected someone to try this
and many of the staff and students will
comment As you stood by are you in
pajamas
excuse me there seems to be a
sleepwalking student on the loose you do
look comfortable an amazing detail you
likely missed can be found on the
character select screen most people
won't see this but if you sit and wait
in this screen depending on how far
through the game and through the side
quests you are interactions will be
shown such as a niffler escaping your
bag in the pursuit of gold coins you
could see a freaking Phoenix diving and
show its face for a while and even the
golden snitch from quidditch other
things include books could be levitated
around the beasts that you've
encountered in your story will nip in
and say hello and even your house elf
will have a changed animation depending
on how he's feeling mine is very happy
and yes my character is really called
Barnaby Sizzle knob thank you so
quidditch is not in Hogwarts Legacy
thanks to a year-long ban from the
Headmaster this year's quidditch season
has been canceled Well the lady that
teaches how to ride a broom can't get
enough of that spot and in her room is a
teeny tiny version of quidditch being
played by minuscule characters a crazy
attention to detail another sport can
also be seen played around the school
it's chess and yes I checked chess is a
spot the pieces here play themselves and
the game is over almost immediately it
turns out it's possible to check meter
player in just two moves and you can see
it in game over and over again and
speaking of Chess we get to play on the
oversized chessboard from the movie in a
side quest right now this Quest is a
PlayStation exclusive which is a bit of
a shame because it's one of the best
quests in the game it even has an upside
down boss fight
Hogwarts Legacy lets us choose a house
to rep during our stay I pick Slytherin
like all the other degenerates in the
world next I wanted to know what happens
if I attempted to enter other house dorm
rooms Gryffindor is behind a portrait of
your mum will she let us in of course
today is
please go away
no password no entrance
I'm coming up with clever passwords day
in day out not as easy as it looks no we
can't enter the Hufflepuff dorm room is
behind the Barrels near the kitchen and
in fact we are told what happens if an
imposter attempts to enter I will
explain what to do but I hesitate to do
it myself as one Arabs knock leads to
being doused in vinegar
most unpleasant let's see if it's true
damn it it is true a full face of
vinegar for any non-hufflepuff students
who get too close oh and by the way
whilst down in the kitchen you'll see
how the food at Hogwarts is made watch
long enough and the real skills are
shown the house elves trample all over
your food never go to Hogwarts
disgusting Hogwarts Legacy is packed
with rare animations and mini little
events I'm sure you've spotted the
quarreling knights in the corridors
every time we venture near them one will
be upsetting the other one with Annoying
humming sounds eventually he can't take
it anymore and this happens
foreign
another ultra rare event can be seen on
the railway tracks there's one single
scripted event in the game that lets us
see the Hogwarts Express but if you are
lucky it will come back every day and
out of Interest I checked if I could get
on board and wow nope it's a ghost train
on the map screen it's possible to spot
a dragon in the skies well it turns out
it's really in game occasionally that
Beast will swoop down for a drink in the
lake or better yet for lunch R.I.P
four-legged friend and as we're in
Scotland I was hoping for a Loch Ness
monster but all I could ride was this
giant squid who will pop up for air
every day or two if this was fortnite
we'd class this as a kraken event oh my
God guys it's happening right now oh my
God guys everyone spamming from the chat
right now if you're excited oh my god oh
and if you choose to be Slytherin be
sure to tap on the glass in your dorm
room and the squid will throw you up a
high five for your efforts whilst here
in your dorm room and playing as a male
character try to get into the girl's
bedroom you'll find just like in the
books the girls have a private space
that no man can enter the stairs become
a ramp and yet Lads away and in other
Doms suits of armor will block the path
completely Harry Potter references are
scattered everywhere in game and some
will be more important to fans than
others like this did you know the jail
cell series Black found himself in is
here in game and you can Venture inside
and by finding this cage door by the
Slytherin bathrooms you will find a
secret ghost party I'm going to ask her
this time you said that 40 years ago
these are death Day Celebrations where
all the ghosts get together and have a
bit of a boogie which I'm told happened
in the books too over in hogsmeade
random NPCs can be spotted looking
through the window of the toys and joke
shop and it so happens that it's
possible to see two identical Ginger
twin boys looking through the glass or
Struck it may just be coincidence but
this could be a nod to the Weasley twins
who would go on to create their own
Wizarding joke shop a century later this
footage is from Dundee by the way have
you noticed the MP PC found around the
world who uses his Wizarding prowess to
conduct a few instruments if you have
the time and the patience and the money
keep tipping him every time you see him
and he'll slowly add more and more
instruments to his orchestra and thank
you each time he sees you I think six is
his limit but I'm not 100 sure yet so
Hogwarts Legacy will go down in history
as a pretty damn good RPG is there
anything else you notice that I didn't
please let me know in the comments and
maybe we'll make a part two I'm Adam
you're awesome it's been a pleasure see
ya
thank you